in the last video we saw that a means
are actually reasonably decent
nucleophiles and in particular we saw
some ethylamine attack some bromomethane
an sn2 reaction and right after that
happened we had some diethyl ammonium
because the nitrogen had given an away
electron to this carbon right over here
so it had a positive charge and so you
had died ethyl ammonium bromide the
bromine had left taking an electron it
then had a negative charge and then we
said that that could actually be an
equilibrium where another ethyl amine
goes and takes a hydrogen from the
diethyl ammonium and turns that into
diethyl amine so we essentially had we
had a primary amine turn into or I guess
you could say converted into a secondary
amine now the one thing that might have
popped into your brain your the end of
that videos hey isn't this also a good
nucleophile isn't this also a good
nucleophile also good nucleophile
alright nucleophile like this and you
say look you know it's got this lone
pair it's more electronegative than the
things that it's bonded with maybe this
two could do a nucleophile attack or
maybe some type of an sn2 react and you
sn2 reaction and you would be correct so
you could imagine if you have some more
if you have some more bromo ethane
hanging around let me draw some more
bromomethane so this is so let me draw
it like this
so this is our bromo group this is our
bromo group and then let's say we have a
hydrogen and we have a hydrogen above
like that this is kind of an upside down
from the last one we did but same idea
then we have another hydrogen behind
just like that and this is obviously a
carbon you could imagine that now you
have this diethyl amine can have an sn2
reaction with the bromomethane so before
was just the ethyl amine now it's the
diethyl amine that's acting as a
nucleophile so this electron right here
in yellow that electron right there in
yellow could be given to this carbon
right at the same time right at the same
time that this
bromine that the bromine leaves and
takes that electron and the bromine
already had one two three four five six
seven valence electrons so after this
happens and this is really almost
identical to what happened in the
previous video except now we are
starting with a secondary amine and
we're going to see it's going to turn
into a tertiary amine as opposed to the
last one we started with a primary amine
we started with a primary amine and
turned into a secondary amine so what's
this going to look like what's kind of
what after we've done the attack so the
bromine will have left it's now the
bromide anion so now we have the bromide
anion it has its Seven original valence
electrons and now it took one more
electron from the carbon it took one
more electron from the carbon it now has
a negative charge and now this ethane
group right here so this carbon right
here is this carbon right over here is
now going to be attached let me draw it
this way is now going to be attached to
this nitrogen so this yellow electron is
now attached to that carbon and it's
bonded to that green electron it's
bonded to this green electron right here
which is which is on the nitrogen
towards that the nitrogen has has and
then this nitrogen has two other ethyl
groups attached to it one two and then
it also has this hydrogen over here
this hydrogen over here and because this
nitrogen gave away an electron it now it
now has a positive charge and I didn't
draw these two hydrogen's here on this
carbon they're implicit I could draw
them there one hydrogen 1 hydrogen and
then another hydrogen but just to make
keep things simple I'm going to leave it
off just so it becomes very clear that
what we now have we now have tri ethyl
tri ethyl let me make this clear so we
have 1 2 3
ethyl groups so now this is tri tri
ethyl tri ethyl and it's a positively
charged nitrogen we have it's bonded to
3 and spun it to 4 thing
it's so and it's essentially given away
an electron so this is triethyl ammonium
tri ethyl ammonium and if you view it as
being an ionic compound with the bromide
then you would call this tri ethyl
ammonium bromide which is kind of this
would be the salt version the ionic
compound right there but we have our tri
ethyl ammonium and then you could
imagine we had that ethyl amine floating
around before if you still have enough
of that ethyl amine floating around so
let me draw some of that ethyl amine
ethyl amine looks like this it has two
hydrogen's it has a lone pair has a
slightly a partially negative charge
right here nitrogen is very
electronegative it it's very its reason
it's the most basic of the neutral
functional groups that we've studied it
might want to capture this hydrogen
proton so it captures it by giving its
electron and then that electron that was
associated with that hydrogen that
hydrogen atom is now given back to this
nitrogen and then you end up with and
then you end up with and I'll once again
I'll draw this as being an equilibrium
I'll do this in equilibrium because one
could swipe the hydrogen from the other
but now this guy over here becomes a
mony or becomes ethyl this guy over here
becomes ethyl ammonium so it has so I'll
draw so this is what he was before and
now he's bonded to this hydrogen so now
he's bonded to this green hydrogen over
here let me make this green just here so
that's ethyl ammonium and we saw this in
the last video
ethyl ammonium and then this guy right
over here and of course you have the
bromide floating around but this guy
over here now is just a nitrogen this is
a nitrogen bonded to three ethyl groups
1 2 3 right it lost its hydrogen gained
electrons so it's now neutral again and
so this guy is tri ethyl amine tri ethyl
tri ethyl amine and since he gained that
electron so we had electron here
electron there so this is the electron
that he already had and then that
magenta electron he gets back and he has
lone bear so you might say hey Sal but
couldn't this guy couldn't try ethyl
amine act as a nucleophile and you would
be right so the triethylamine if you
still have some of that bromo ethane
hanging around if you still have some of
that bromomethane hanging around so let
me draw some bromo ethane and obviously
there's some hydrogen here there's some
hydrogen here if you have some more of
that bromomethane all right hanging
around this guy could that attack that
bromo ethane and then you would be left
with you would be left with what would
that look like so you would have let me
do it in that same color so then that
green color you have the nitrogen it has
its three original ethane groups or
ethyl groups that's attached to it has
this electron but it's now bonded to
this carbon over here and that let me I
want to be very clear this was an sn2
reaction so jit right when it attacks
that carbon right it attacks that carbon
this bromine and we saw this multiple
times can take its take that other
electron from the carbon and so this
becomes another bromide anion I'm going
this a little bit faster than the past
because we've seen this many many many
many times and now this guy is attached
to this ethyl group so this ethyl group
I could just draw like this the ethyl
group draw like this
he gave this carbon this magenta
electron right there and so we have this
new bond and I could also draw the
hydrogen's we have this hydrogen and
this hydrogen we could draw them off
like this hydrogen and hydrogen but that
makes the drawing a little bit more
confusing but what just happened what
just happened this guy gave it away
electron let me make it clear he gave
away electrons so he has now a positive
charge
you have the bromine turn into bromide
it took an electron but what is this now
this is this is tetra ethyl ammonium so
this is we have four it's a quarter
narrower I could never say it right
coronary coronary a mean we're actually
not even it's an ammonium so this is
tetra tetra tetra four four one two
3:4 tetraethyl tetraethyl ammonium
ammonium instead of a mean because it
has that positive charge the nitrogen
has four bonds it's given away an
electron tetraethylammonium and then if
you view it as a salt with the bromide
anion is tetraethyl ammonium bromide
bromide so the whole point of really
this video and the last video is one the
last video i just wanted to show you
that an amine it's reasonably basic can
act as a nucleophile and show you how it
would react show you mechanism but what
I want to show you in this video is that
that reaction just keep going and so
when you start with the original
ingredients when you started with the
when you started with the ethyl amine
and the bromomethane you might said oh
this is pretty simple you're just going
to end up with a little bit of diethyl
amine but the reality is you're going to
end up with all of the stuff it's going
to be all mixed up in every different
way going to end up with some ethyl
amine diethyl amine in there you have
some ethyl amine in there you're going
to have some ammonium in there you'll
have some tri ethyl ammonium in there
you'll have some you'll have some ethyl
ammonium in there I mean you're going to
have a little bit you're going to have a
little bit of everything a little bit of
everything let me be clear here what did
I I just want to make sure I don't I
didn't miss a name any of this stuff no
yes I think I named it cry sometimes I
get confused with the ammonium Zanda
means but the whole point of this is
that this reaction could keep going and
that they can this sn2 reaction can keep
occurring in a bunch of different ways